if life were a game and all of us are
given a token to like enter like a
casino we sit down at the table to play
poker right and everybody's playing
everybody's got cards and we got to play
the handward dog and depending on our
level of skill we amass more and more
chips throughout the game at the end of
the game the difference between the real
world and in the game of life in the
real world you go and you can cash out
your chips and you walk out with money
and there you go there's your day but I
feel like in the casino of life you get
tapped on the shoulder by the Grim
Reaper he says your time's up and then
all your tips get pushed right back to
the middle of the table and then you
leave the casino empty-handed because it
was a fake game with fake rules it
didn't matter we accumulate these chips
that I'm just gonna push back in the
middle again that other people are going
to play on the reason that that analogy
became real for me is like I bought this
piece of land and I was like that's neat
how many people have owned this piece of
land the guy before me owned it and the
guy before him owned it and the guy
before him done it and they were like
this is mine they're just chips that
just get played with and they just get
amassed and then they get redistributed
it just doesn't matter it's really for
nothing and so like if you want you can
build something that you think is cool
but like at the end of the day like
we're just gonna catch the chips